meanwhile the otas were rolling in san
francisco and quarterback jimmy
garoppolo met with the media here is an
exchange from his session regarding his
reaction to the news that the 49ers were
going all in to draft his replacement
jimmy when we first talked to kyle after
the trade was made he said he called you
and that you were understandably pissed
that you that you weren't thrilled about
it can you can you take us back to what
your emotions were like was there ever a
time where you considered asking for a
trade or or anything like that in the
ensuing time after all
uh
yeah i mean when it initially happened
there's a million emotions that go on
throughout your head and you think of
all the possible scenarios and things
like that but uh
you know at the end of the day i won't
play football i want to go out there and
win games that's what i do and so um you
know it wasn't anything too crazy took a
little while to get to get you know
process everything but you know once i
did it was just go out there and ball uh
you know you just gotta attack it nfl is
a crazy business things happen but you
just gotta attack it day by day and you
know make the best of it
hey look
at
and you're gonna have a ton of emotions
when you took a team to a super bowl
and then
you suffer an ankle injury on turf that
the team believed was substandard week
two of the season you spend the whole
year trying to recover from that you end
up missing 10 games and you had the
fluke acl tear before that and now all
of a sudden they've written you off
they're done with you of course you're
going to think about every possible
scenario but chris
demanding a trade
who's going to take on the jimmy
garoppolo contract hey i demand a trade
well jimmy we can't find anyone who's
going to pay you 25 million this year so
are you going to take 12 million to
facilitate a trade what are you going to
do his best play financially is to do
exactly what he's done and to hope that
they don't come to him in late august
and say we're good with trey lance you
better take a pay cut to 12 million or
we're going to cut you loose which i
still think is on the table i still
think that could happen but his only
path to making 25 million this year and
that has to be a real consideration i
mean you're putting in the same effort
you're putting in the same work you're
still in the nfl you're going to just
give up half your salary no his only way
to get that full salary was to stay
exactly where he is and hope that they
decide to keep them around and as jed
york said after the draft make a 50
million commitment over the next two
years
to develop trey lance by paying jimmy
garoppolo to still be on the team yeah i
mean mike i mean first off i think
you're exactly right that has to be
taken into account i mean it has to be
it'd be crazy every human like wait oh
i'm gonna make 25 million if i ask to be
traded i might get half yes so there's
that aspect you know there's nothing
wrong with him asking to be traded or at
least having those thoughts go through
his head i mean come on i mean the
off-season started out with oh the 49ers
are you know in the uh matthew stafford
they they're trying to get into that
trade you you heard rumors about maybe
they'd be interested in desean watson
and then of course all the draft stuff
happened so he's probably just like an
avalanche all the time holy cow are they
trying to get rid of me and doing
anything they can
yeah that's going to make people want to
get traded but i think between the point
of what you brought up the money
situation
and then the other aspect of
you know
okay maybe if you went to new england
you could go there and have great
success and do those things but the
payment 25. i know but they're not gonna
pay them 25 you're exactly right and you
know other than that my point is the
place you're at
is really good with quarterbacks and
offenses and winning and all those type
of things too to where i think as a
quarterback you look at it and go well
man i know maybe they don't love me here
and those there's issues
but i still think i can be my best
player and be the best me here on this
team with the supporting cast and what
we've done already and i think between
those two things that's probably why he
you know decided not to pursue that
by the way george kittle who has been
all in with jimmy garoppolo over the
past few years making the subtle or not
so subtle pivot to trey lance praising
what he's seen so far from
trey lance because at some point trey
lance is going to be the guy who's
throwing the football to george kittle
and kittle more than smart enough to
understand that that's the direction the
wind is blowing the question continues
to be when will jimmy garoppolo be blown
out of san francisco they they i think
holding out hope that they're going to
have an opportunity to trade him get
good value he gets his 25 million it's
gonna need to involve some sort of an
injury to another quarterback otherwise
they may indeed cut him before the start
of the season if trey lance is ready but
surely that's what the 49ers are trying
to do get the guy ready as soon as
possible
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports